[Music]
this is my compost bin
it's where i put used coffee grounds
melon rinds corn husks
pretty much anything that was a plant in
its former life
along with shredded up newspapers junk
mail and pizza boxes
if i wait long enough something kind of
amazing happens
all that stuff is transformed into
well what looks like ordinary dirt but
this
dirt is anything but ordinary this dirt
is alive yes it's full of earthworms
we'll get to them
but it's also full of millions of tiny
creatures
that you need a microscope to see you
wouldn't know by looking at them
but these little guys hold the key to
human civilization
without it human life as we know it
wouldn't be possible
which makes it all the more puzzling
when you discover
that its number one enemy is
us
so not all dirt is created equal it can
have
more or less of those little living
creatures in it
and there's an easy way to tell even if
you don't have a microscope at home
first put about a handful of dirt in a
clear glass jar
this is some soil that i collected from
the worm bin don't worry i took out the
worms later
and this i dug up from my backyard next
add some water screw the lids on nice
and tight
and shake them up and now we wait
okay it's been a day we're back and we
can see that both of our samples
have separated into distinct layers you
can see that they look
really different let's look closer at
the dirt from the backyard
it has a bunch of stuff on the bottom
gravel sand
silt and clay and this stuff floating at
the top
is called humus that's where all the
microscopic creatures live
scientists call them microfauna micro
for small
fauna for animals there are millions of
different kinds
when old plants die the microfauna eat
them
and then well they poop that waste
is full of nutrients that the new baby
plants
need to grow grass tomatoes apple trees
no matter the plant the process is the
same
and the more microfauna there are in the
soil eating
pooping doing their thing the bigger and
healthier
the plants over millions of years the
new plants would use up nutrients in the
soil
then the microfauna would replace those
nutrients by eating the dead plants
and mild climates the microfauna could
build up about two and a half
centimeters or one
inch of humus every 500 years
evolution continued and eventually
produced a species
who changed this process forever
homo sapiens have been around for almost
200 000 years
but we didn't start farming until about
12 000 years ago
before then we still depended on healthy
soil for food
the grass that fed the herd animals we
hunted the nut trees and berry plants
that we foraged
these all grew from the rich humus that
the microfauna created
farming developed at various points in
time in different regions of the world
and from the beginning some of those
early farmers recognized the
relationship between healthy soil
and healthy plants like the iroquois in
the eastern part of what is now
the united states the first farmers
there
women by the way planted corn atop
mounds of soil every spring
after they harvested the corn in the
fall they left the dead corn stalks atop
the mound
all winter long the microfauna broke
them down into nutrient-rich
humus the next spring's new baby corn
plants
would use those nutrients and start the
cycle again
iroquois farmers also planted beans and
squash in the same plot
together these three crops were known as
the three sisters
and not only did this combination make
for a balanced diet of protein
carbohydrates and crucial vitamins for
the iroquois people
it also kept the microfauna in the soil
happy
healthy and pooping
early farmers in other parts of the
world developed different ways to feed
the soil
like in the amazon river basin early
farmers there
used controlled fires to create patches
of rich humus
today if you dig deep into that soil you
can see
that it's much darker and healthier than
the regular tropical soil nearby
all over the world the earliest farmers
found ways to care for the soil so that
it would produce healthy plants
but slowly as european colonists
descended on various parts of the world
these ancient practices gave way to a
new
type of farming
[Music]
machines like the steam engine and the
power loom transformed life in europe
and then in north america
starting in the mid 1700s the lure of
factory wages
drew people from the countryside into
the cities which meant the farmers who
stayed on the land
needed to produce more food to be
shipped to those cities
farmers got stuck in a cycle of constant
harvesting
without giving the soil time to
regenerate the nutrients it had built up
over generations the soil quickly wore
out
so they responded by cutting down
forests and turning them into fields
in north america european settlers used
violence to push the iroquois and other
indigenous people
further west away from the three sisters
fields that had sustained them for
thousands of years
when they had stripped that soil of its
life the settlers kept moving west
seizing indigenous lands along the way
new steel plows
helped them break up the hard heavy soil
of the great plains
but these new steel plows did something
else
they turned up the soil over and over
again
which killed a lot of those microfauna
that had been living in the soil
making humus and when gasoline-powered
tractors showed up
in the early 1900s their weight pressed
down on the increasingly lifeless soil
making it
even harder for plants to grow by the
1930s
the soil of the great plains had lost so
much of its microfauna
that giant dust storms pummeled the
region
and thousands of families lost their
farms
this new type of farming wasn't limited
to europe and north america
the small farms that had sustained the
indigenous peoples of central and south
america for generations
had been replaced by giant mega farms
haciendas run by the spanish and
portuguese settlers
and worked by indigenous and enslaved
people
the crops they grew didn't feed the
people there the fields were full of
sugar cane and cotton which were shipped
out of the country to factories
and just like in north america the
overworked soil quickly crumbled and
started to wash away
in response farmers around the world
started to rely on chemical fertilizers
which help crops grow quickly but can
also pollute drinking water
and kill fish and other types of aquatic
life
according to the united nations
practices like this are
killing the humus so quickly we may run
out of healthy soil
in less than 60 years that is
if we keep doing things the same way
[Applause]
remember the soil we tested that these
guys helped to make
look at it next to the jar of backyard
soil
see how there's way more humus floating
on the top
more of this stuff is exactly what we
need
all over the world to replace the soil
we've already destroyed
and earthworms can help on farms where
years of plowing
has damaged the soil a handful of
farmers have
stopped doing it instead they roll down
the old crop
then use a series of drills to plant the
new seeds
underneath the old dead stalks
because this method doesn't disturb the
soil it gives earthworms a chance to
make humus
and to create these tunnels that help
water get to the plant roots
it also helps to loosen the soil so that
plant roots can spread
but this method has been slow to catch
on just one in four american farmers use
it
on many smaller farms though earthworms
are a big
part of the operation this is our worm
bin
it's the hardest workers and these are
actually red wiggler worms
this is mark white he showed me around
his urban farm
right in the middle of cleveland ohio
the raspberries i talked about
i just pulled one off like that yeah
oh my god you made awesome everything is
based on the soil
everything that we eat is a reflection
of the soil this right here this is the
black gold
on mark's farm that process starts here
in the compost pile
over time wood chips and food waste
break down
with the help of earthworms and
microfauna so this is how the soil you
saw inside is how it starts out
in the next 10 15 20 years this whole
footprint would have been
improved so much more by having been
here
[Music]
we need healthy soil to grow healthy
food
and we need healthy food to grow healthy
people
it's all connected dirt is so much more
than the stuff beneath our feet
it's the stuff of life and the sooner we
realize that
the better off we'll be
you